the ones who walk there's a sense of
entitlement I'm not quite sure where the
hell it came from but you know somehow I
look good and I should have that part
what is wrong with you people don't you
recognize my talent I'm brilliant and
I'm talented and I'm handsome and I have
nice breasts on my butt and I dress look
at how sexy I am what is wrong with you
all I was only just that all maybe you a
minute or so you landing here for a year
they look just like you would the same
but suppressing community and thank you
for competition do you think it's a
generational attitude or do you think
that the mind of most I mean there's a
level of narcissism and we all have it
but do you think that's just part of an
artist persona a bit or is it a
generational thing I think it's both I
think for art in terms of our industry I
think it's a sense of artistry and the
rest of it but there's something about
like I say okay there was between
waiting to be discovered by someone and
discovering yourself it's like being
discovered discovering yourself is a
different consciousness sure and I think
the newbies now are there's some kind of
entitlement mentality but is partially
our fault too because we have not
prepared them for this and so you know
the Lindsay Lohan's of the world was
those kids I feel sorry for them you
know that then the media just torches
and just devours them but I mean you'd
make a couple of films you think hey
you've made it you know and you take a
script to somebody and you say
I know I made those films but now I'm
gonna make this one and they tell you
I'm gonna say this once shut your
goddamn mouth sit down and don't come
back in till I call you
you have no power
that's kind of a painful thing and if
you don't have God in your life or
meditation or something
you're gonna take something to kill that
pain and you've got to take something
the alcohol drugs with ecstasy but the
point is is that this is a business of
rejection and I'm not so sure this
generation is understands the layers of
the rejection the levels of the
rejection people who won Grammys let's
say in music um two years ago where are
they today have heard the names people
have started movement nice movies
independent movies did a great job
where's their next film there's 30 film
or whatever
I'm just something saying it's it's a
business rejection and if you think
because you have talent that that is
what's gonna get you through I think
you're in for a painful journey but if
you have the understanding of a
businessperson and you're creating maybe
your website a webisode company and
you're creating your something else and
plus your film and you're in strategic
alliances with the people you're you may
have a shot and you may take that next
role you get in leverage look at Queen
Latifah I mean he Latifah was a rapper
made a couple of movies and have a
clothing line now his own show and
producing movies
you want to follow an example of a
business person if I was a woman in this
business I'd look at her I mean I a lot
of pretty actresses out here were acting
but those look saying all this I mean
they got mass then after 32 you're I
mean I'm not jumpy meaning it's they
just don't take you seriously so what
are you gonna do weep and cry or you're
gonna say I get it
and from this edge at this stage I'm
gonna leverage everything you give me
into my future which is owning my
content
you